1900 milliards de dollars pour relancer
l'économie
c'est le pari de joe biden quelques
jours avant de prendre les rênes du pays
le président élu dévoile un nouveau plan
de relance d'urgence
objectif sortir les etats-unis de la
situation liée à la pandémie de covin 19
la pire crise économique du pays depuis
des années 30
pour joe biden la reprise de l'économie
commence par l'accélération de la
campagne de vaccination
le programme de vaccination aux états
unis a été un échec lamentable jusqu'à
présent demain j'établirai notre plan de
vaccination pour corriger le tir et
atteindre notre objectif de 100 millions
de vaccinations à la fin de mai 100
premiers jours demande pour que les
parents puissent retourner au travail
joe biden s'est engagé à rouvrir les
écoles dans les 100 premiers jours de
son mandat
il promet également des aides pour les
familles américaines
notre plan de relance comprend également
une aide immédiate aux américains les
plus touchés et les plus démunis nous
allons terminer le travail constituant à
fournir un total de 2000 $ en espèces
aux personnes qui en ont le plus besoin
les 600 dollars déjà alloués ne sont
tout simplement pas suffisant de weiden
n'a pas manqué une occasion de tacler
son prédécesseur mais cela ne
l'empêchent pas de reprendre à son
compte le made in america marque de
fabrique de donald trump
nous utiliserons l'argent des
contribuables pour reconstruire
l'amérique nous achèterons des produits
américains
soutenant des millions d'emplois
industriels américains renforcer notre
compétitivité dans un monde de plus en
plus compétitif je sais que ce que je
viens de décrire n'est pas sans coûts
mais ne pas le faire nous coûtera cher
reste à joe biden de convaincre le
congrès de voter ce texte et débloquer
les 1900 milliards de dollars
nécessaires
moins d'une semaine avant d'entrer à la
maison blanche il lui faudra notamment
gagné la confiance des élus républicains
qui avaient déjà voté au printemps
dernier le plan de 2200 milliards de
dollars du président trump